entire neighborhoods have burned to the
ground destroying more than property Jan
Gilbert is among the thousands of
Australians who have begun to go back
home to nothing
rubble and debris now cover what's left
of her belongings all of my positions
have been totally incinerated everything
there is just simply nothing in other
areas the bush fires are far from over
thousands of firefighters are struggling
in the states of Victoria in New South
Wales an area that's home to more than
13 million people and the conditions are
expected to get worse
over the next few days the winds are
expected to be very strong back to 40
plus degrees temperatures we've got a
lot of fire in the landscape that we
will not contained in the town of Ulla
doula people wait outside supermarkets
to stock up on food and water power and
mobile phone outages are also a concern
you have a challenge with getting people
able to even access the basics like
petrol and electricity and that's
causing enormous stress for communities
we understand that the Australian
military is using planes and helicopters
to thousands of flames while preparing
for possible evacuations
emergency crews are stretched thin and
slight changes in temperatures and the
wind could spark even more fires it
wasn't much they could do a kind that
quick and I just couldn't do anything it
was just gear and the wind just blew and
then wind just blew and if you look at
everything I mean it's just grass it's
just everything everywhere you go it
left nothing no one knows yet the
precise cost of the damage but it's
clear the widespread devastation is
immense
Katya lupus of a yawn al-jazeera